adrian hauser trying to pick things up
rock it's been a tough go for him over
his last six starts yeah he was really
good his first two starts a 75 earned
run average in his first two last six
over seven so he's looking to turn
things around trying to take care of
contreras who's been the hottest cubs
hitter in the last dozen games averaged
nearly 400
1-2
and he chased down in the way of the
breaking ball it's a clean one two three
inning for adrian houser alex mills
making start number nine first ever
start in miller park second start
against the brewers
this year
kesten hira
started every game for milwaukee
full count
change up swung on and missed strike
three
both teams go one two three in the first
two out walk first time the brewers have
had traffic on the shortstop arcia right
right match up they're going in
bounce played by kipnis so to complete
on a sunday afternoon
nothing nothing
one out one on here's baez
zeal one hit on the ground to third and
soulguard couldn't handle it so that'll
be another
brewers error two men on with one down
let's see if that play represents a
turning point jason hayward at the plate
in the pitch and that ball will land in
left and the cubs will grab the lead
schwarber scores it's one to nothing
there's the first hit jason hayward
having a great series he pulls in its
second with a double in fact as baez
motored to third cubs lead one to
nothing he sent kipnis at the plate cubs
lead one to nothing
ground ball and they're going to throw
nowhere
everybody's safe houses are looking for
some help defensively and he hasn't
gotten much the last two innings i don't
know if hira really had a play on baez
but
his goal was to throw to the plate yeah
infield and he charges this ball
aggressively
almost took a page out of the harlem
globetrotters there going
here to hauser to first but they did not
get the out
so two nothing first and third and the
batter is victor caratini
the 1-0 to carratini fly ball shallow
center that ball is gonna fall in for a
base hit hayward comes in to score cubs
lead three to nothing everything going
the cubs way in the inning carratini did
not hit the ball hard but he'll take it
there's hap with three on and three
already in
lined and it'll get in there
kipnis scores carratini right behind him
five nothing
five-nothing cubs over the brewers one
away here in the top half of the fifth
inning jason kipnis at the plate
at the end of the bat
and yelich
will make the catch
schwarber will score also baez safe at
third six to nothing sac fly kipnis he's
knocked in two today
and
hobby scores
it's seven to nothing so javi always
heads up apparently time was not called
craig castle is going to come out of the
dugout craig council
is
probably not going to stop until he's
kicked out
[Music]
i get the sense reading the body
language to correct that his heart's not
really into it
maybe starting to warm to the task now
council's argument has to be that the
ball was the ball
or the play should have been dead and
shut down
that's got to be his argument that the
play is done and time is out
don't take your eyes off of el [ __ ]
council continue to press there you go
there's the there's the obligatory
heave-ho
so carratini draws a two-out walk and
that'll bring up david bodie cubs
leading the brewers seven to nothing
they've already scored twice here in
this fifth inning
can't do it
boney deep left is it fair it is
gone
two run homer it's nine
nothing
alec mills has continued to be very
sharp here today how long he can
maintain this no-hit effort
hayward in right
so alec mills leading 9-0 as a hit bid
through five
mills has still not given up a base hit
through seven innings stay tuned we go
to the eighth he's gonna take a no-no
into the eighth
with a 10-0 lead
brewers without a run without a hit i
can't really think of too many balls
hard hit against mills all day slow
curveball popped up foul might be
playable for carratini it is out number
one
and everybody
at the railing in the cubs dugout
watching mills
ground ball backhanded baez
he gets him two away
we're on the edge of our seats he's on
the edge of the strike zone a swinging a
pop fly on the infield playable for
bodhi at third he's got it
and alec mills has not allowed a base
hit through eight innings alec mills out
to work the bottom of the ninth inning
jacob nottingham is first up mel's
coming back 1-0 swinging a pop-up right
side might be playable for rizzo he's
got it out number one
rizzo and foul territory ran right
through the coaches box
and grabbed that ball on the run mills
two outs away from history
tyrone taylor's first plate appearance
the one-two serve he got him swinging
two down
mills now is one out away jace peterson
at the plate he is one out away
[Applause]
[Music]
the former college walk-on has made
history
in milwaukee's
alec mills has just pitched a no-hitter
a no-hitter for cubs right-hander alec
mills a ground ball to baez a routine
play the cubs are mobbing the young
right-hander on the mound jumping up and
down
what a great moment for alec mills as
the cubs win the ball game
to nothing